megan good and devon franklin are going
their separate ways after nine years of
marriage but the good thing is with with
this one with my husband the respect
that i have for him is so totally
different than any other relationship
that i've been in according to legal
docs obtained by e.t filed by franklin
on monday in los angeles the couple's
separation date is listed as august 21st
of this year the reason cited for
divorce is irreconcilable differences
the couple also released a statement
confirming the news
saying quote after much prayer and
consideration we have decided to go in
our futures separately but forever
connected
adding there was quote no one at fault
for the separation
megan and devon got married in 2012
after meeting on the set of jumping the
broom and i had spent enough time around
her we had made a movie together called
jumping the broom and i got a chance to
get a friendship with her and see who
she was and god gave me the vision to
see this is who she is and she's for you
despite the split both shared tributes
to one another on their anniversary
[Music]
good shared this video montage with the
caption quote to the love of my life my
husband purpose partner happy
anniversary
even more recently earlier this month
devon praised his ex's performance on
the amazon prime series harlem i'm such
a fan of your work i've read all three
of your book camille parks
can i call you back that's fine dr
pruitt i'll talk to you later sorry he
wrote on instagram quote i'm so proud of
my love megan good
she's one of the most talented actors on
the planet
listen
i don't care how
rational
loving
we are
we are people who need help
communicating devon opened up to e.t
about he and megan attending therapy and
why he calls friend will smith one of
his mentors why did counseling help you
all because i feel like you guys both
have are very rational people and have
the tools to but why did counseling help
communicating is the hardest thing
why because there's a lot of stuff
that's deep down on the inside i hear
will smith and jada pinkett smith talk
about that like we go to therapy
individually and then come together oh
yeah oh yeah you know to figure it out
yeah no it's it is that has made such a
huge huge impact and will is you know i
mean a mentor and a friend and has been
very helpful to me in terms of helping
me do the work that i need to do as a
man yeah to be a better man to be a
better husband and some issues that
you're trying to sort out collectively
are individual issues right like my
trauma i bring that to the marriage but
i still have to have a path to work out
that trauma right and sometimes i'm
bringing that trauma to the marriage and
i'm realizing wait wait the issue we're
having is because i haven't been doing
my work or the issue we're having
because she hasn't been doing her work
so having those individual therapists
really do help us stay accountable to
ourselves